allowing members state economic policies  was the target set by the EU is the  mantra of the European semester it is a  cycle of six months negotiations  allowing the 28 EU member states to  coordinate structural reforms and budget  policies and preventing macro economic  disparities was in the EU novel yauger  gotta leave degreaser DC opposes  exceptional oh no sepa commence upon evo  a google amanda zuluaga valrico directly  not huge it there before in generation  you deserve less all before a good read  let alone she travel on to improve this  coordination MEP is a calling for  statistical indicators from measuring  the impact of policies adopted I  proposes introduction of three  employment indicators namely the  activity rates the youth employment  rates and the long-term unemployment  rates in March 2016 member states will  formulate their policies aimed for the  year ahead they will be caught to take  on board the recommendations made in the  European semester negotiations